und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
abend der außenminister der ukraine ist
zu besuch in deutschland und es ist dem
offenkundig ein anliegen die beziehungen
zwischen kiew und berlin in ein gutes
licht zu stellen damit knüpft er direkt
an den besuch von annalena baerbock an
der gerade erst aus der ukraine
zurückgekehrt ist und sich dort viel
sympathie erwartet an manchen stellen
clinton dimitrow kollege heute fast wie
ein psychologe der den deutschen vor
allem deutschen sozialdemokraten
einfühlsamen dabei hilft ihr putin
trauma zu überwinden
etwa wenn er sagt dass der bundeskanzler
und seine partei stark genug sind
einzugestehen dass die vorherige politik
gescheitert ist und sie eine neue
politik brauchen ich habe da zu
verhindern ein interview mit ihm geführt
doch zunächst berichtet mathis feldhoff
aus berlin
es ist ein besuch der wunden heilen soll
spannung überwinden kann das schwierige
verhältnis der deutschen
sozialdemokraten zur ukraine in den
letzten wochen reparieren muss dimitri
kohl war der ukrainische außenminister
geht heute einen schritt auf die spd zu
das vermeintlich unkritische verhältnis
der sozialdemokraten zu russland ändere
sich gerade so der außenminister als der
krieg begann war es der deutsche kanzler
der die sozialdemokraten repräsentiert
der die wende einleitete bei
waffenlieferungen bei nordstream 2 und
der eine neue politik gegenüber russland
ankündigte für den spd-fraktionschef
mütze nicht keine einfache situation
wochenlang hatte er gerade mit dem
ukrainischen botschafter über kreuz
gelegen insbesondere bei
waffenlieferungen noch vor 14 tagen
hatte mütze nicht in einem brief
indirekt die tweets mannix hart
kritisiert mit den kritikern die
tatsachen teils unterschlagen teils
bewusst falsch darstellen weil niemand
anders als der botschafter gemeint mütze
nicht kann nur schwer aus seiner haut
waffenlieferungen hält er immer noch für
falsch aber er verschließt sich nicht
der solidarität
wir sind uns einig darüber dass die
brutale aggression russlands nicht
hinnehmbar ist uns ist wichtig dass wir
als bundesrepublik an der seite der
ukraine stehen solidarisch an der seite
der ukraine stehen und dass wir
unterstützen cola hat längst das nächste
projekt für das tier von berlin
unterstützung erhofft unterstützung die
offen gewährt wird bei der union genauso
wie bei den grünen das ist der
kandidatenstatus zugeben den man jetzt
schnell wie geht es nach der
herzlichkeit der bilder scheint die
ukraine sehr willkommen
am nachmittag beim vizekanzler gibt es
sogar eine ganz besondere begrüßung
herzlich willkommen im ministerium für
wirtschaft klimaschutz und unterstützung
für die ukraine denn so fühlt es sich
tatsächlich an hier zu arbeiten
es sind die signale der grünen minister
etwa der besuch von annalena baerbock zu
beginn der woche als sie in butter den
ort der kriegsverbrechen besucht die von
der ukrainischen seite als besonders
solidarisch wahrgenommen werden habeck
weiß natürlich dass ein eu-beitritt mit
hürden verbunden ist deshalb formuliert
er mit bedacht das wird jetzt klug
vorzubereiten seien wie die schrittfolge
so ist dass sie erreichbar ist aber eben
auch keine falschen versprechungen
gegeben werden die nicht eingehalten
werden so der diplomatische streit
scheint weitgehend beigelegt was die
ukraine nicht hindert neue wünsche zu
formulieren weil die alten russischen
waffen bald verbraucht sein braucht man
jetzt moderne etwa kampfflugzeuge so der
außenminister in einem interview
und der außenminister der ukraine in die
metro cholera ist nun im heute-journal
guten abend herr kollege
li ning guten abend sie haben heute
gesagt deutschland spiele jetzt in
europa die erste geige wie meinen sie
das
wir in der ukraine glauben dass
deutschland
eines der führenden länder in europa ist
und wir erwarten immer dass deutschland
in den kritischen fragen immer eine
führende rolle ein nimmt auch wenn es um
die entwicklung europas und der
sicherheit und des wohlstandes in europa
geht und wenn wir nicht sehen dass
deutschland eine solche führungsrolle
übernimmt dann ist das frustrierend für
uns und wir verstehen nicht weshalb dass
nichts geschieht
einer der gründe weshalb ich heute hier
bin ist tatsächlich um mit deutschland
die strategien zu diskutieren und ich
bin durchaus zufrieden mit der qualität
der diskussion die wir bisher gehabt
haben und auch dem wirklich fruchtbaren
dialog war die ukraine in letzter zeit
eigentlich eher frustriert wie sie eben
ja auch andeuteten und bei dem thema
schwere waffen und waffen ist
deutschland bislang ja überhaupt nicht
erste geige haben sie denn jetzt
inzwischen erkenntnisse wann sie gibt
einen panzer bekommen und ob die dann
auch schießen können
ich glaube und wir in der ukraine
glauben das ist drei kritische punkte
gibt wo es tatsächlich eine
führungsrolle braucht um europa schützen
zu können da geht es um die
waffenlieferung an die ukraine aber auch
um die sanktionen gegen russland und den
eu kandidatenstatus für die ukraine wenn
es also um die waffen frage geht ja da
reißen wir die entscheidungen von
kanzler scholz sehr willkommen jetzt die
politik zurück zu lassen oder hinter
sich zu lassen keine waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern ich glaube ich noch
am ersten tag der russischen aggression
dann verkündet wurde das war jetzt eine
veränderung wir haben natürlich auch
einige leichtere waffensysteme von
deutschland bekommen das war schon
hilfreich aber sie haben recht jetzt
brauchen wir schwere waffensysteme und
ich bin gestern in berlin angekommen
habe auch gelesen dass es ebenfalls eine
gruppe ukrainischer offiziere gibt die
jetzt in deutschland an panzerhaubitzen
ausgebildet werden sollen wo die
deutsche bundesregierung
zugesagt hat diese jetzt zu und liefern
und wir werden jetzt als offiziere haben
die diese haubitzen auch dienen können
und das ist wirklich eine große hilfe
und ich möchte annalena baerbock und den
mitgliedern der deutschen regierung
dafür danken dass sie diese entscheidung
getroffen haben aber ganz konkret ist
noch kein kanzler bei ihnen angekommen
oder
nein denn unsere
militär angehören müssen natürlich erst
einmal daran ausgebildet werden und dann
werden sie auch in die ukraine zurück
aber man muss schon auch sagen das ist
eben nicht besonders lang dauert um
diese ausbildung auch durchzuführen
wenigstens weniger lang als die
entscheidung diese waffen auch zu
liefern offensichtlich die zögerlichkeit
der bundesregierung in sachen waffen hat
auch damit zu tun dass es hierzulande
auch ängste gibt die auch bundeskanzler
scholz in einem interview ende april
selbst formulierte und sagte wir dürfen
nicht hier in einem dritten weltkrieg
geraten und wir dürfen sich in einen
atomkrieg geraten was sagen sie dazu
ich sehe tatsächlich
nichts die möglichkeit dass ein
nuklearer krieg hier als möglichkeit auf
dem tisch lege denn das wäre der letzte
krieg also auch für russland der zweite
punkt ist der dass ich natürlich immer
die gespräche auch weiter fortführen
möchte selbst wenn sie mit den worten
beginnen dass wir keine waffen an die
ukraine liefern sollten weil der krieg
dadurch die skaliert werden wenn wir
dieser logik folgten dann wäre der
zweite satz dass wir uns wünschten dass
russland die ukraine besiegen soll und
dass sie akzeptierten dass kosten und
mehr ukrainer und ukrainerinnen solltet
mehr grausamkeiten auch verübt um eine
eskalation zu vermeiden aber ich möchte
alle daran erinnern dass es nicht die
ukraine oder die nato oder die oder
deutschland oder die europäische union
waren die die situation eskaliert haben
die einen akt der aggression begangen
habe ich denke es ist im besten
interesse aller westeuropäischen ländern
hier einigkeit zu zeigen und der ukraine
alles bereit zu stellen was die ukraine
braucht um eben auch muss man auf dem
territorium der ukraine zu besiegen und
ihnen nicht zuzugestehen weiter
voranzuschreiten sie sagten heute auch
brauchen taten sie vor allem zum
beispiel auch kampfflugzeuge das ist ja
auch ein alter wunsch der ukraine aber
da kam jetzt schon auch von annalena
baerbock von der sehr sehr viel
verständnis ansonsten haben eigentlich
ein ziemlich deutliches wenn auch
diplomatisch formuliert dass jetzt die
enttäuscht sind sie darüber
die ukraine
gibt all den verschiedenen ländern eine
liste dessen was wir brauchen und jedes
land kann sich tatsächlich entscheiden
dem sie auswählen können die zur
verfügung stellen können wenn
deutschland keine kampfflugzeuge zur
verfügung stellen kann ist okay dann
suchen wir wollen das aber es gibt
durchaus dinge auf dieser liste die wir
von deutschland bekommen können wie
beispielsweise panzerhaubitzen und die
regierung hat hier ihre entscheidung
getroffen und die
entsprechende transport wird jetzt auch
vorbereitet das heißt nicht dass wir
jetzt von allen ländern fordern die
kampfflugzeuge bekommt wenn das nicht
möglich ist dann verstehen wir dass wir
sind vernünftige menschen wir verstehen
so etwas das ist jetzt natürlich auch
der diplomat der da spricht es heißt
immer die ukraine darf nicht verlieren
und russland darf nicht gewinnen können
sie dieses kriegsziel der näher
definieren was ist das kriegsziel der
ukraine einschließlich grimm und don was
die alten gebiete zurück zu bekommen
oder zurück zum 24 februar
auch immer nötig ist und ganz gleich wie
lange es dauert die ukraine wird
militärisch und auch diplomatisch dafür
kämpfen dass unser land vollständig
wiederhergestellt hat in seiner gesamten
territorialen integrität natürlich
einschließlich des dollars und der krim
aber es gibt immer einschränkungen auch
für das militärische szenario wir sehen
den aktuellen status quo auf dem
schlachtfeld
das element des donners bei der frage
der territorialen integrität der ukraine
das ist der ort wo tatsächlich die
schlachten augenblick geschlagen werden
und die situation kann sich jederzeit
ändern und wenn wir stark genug sind
dann werden wir natürlich russland
herausdrängen aber ich möchte
unterstreichen dass durch den beginn
einer militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine und durch die anerkennung dieser
sogenannte volksrepublik russland die
minsker vereinbarungen getötet hat ab
getötet hat und deswegen gibt es keine
verpflichtung keinerlei zusagen wir von
keiner seite der donners ist ein
schlachtfeld wo die stärksten gewinnen
werden was halten sie sich also offen
herr polizist gab sehr herzliche bilder
von ihnen und annalena baerbock als
jetzt in kiew war man man sagen wie sie
beide sich dann auch wirklich in den
armen lagen dann ist das natürlich bei
annalena baerbock auch einfach weil sie
auch schon vorm krieg eine eindeutige
haltung hatte die interessante frage ist
wann werden wir
herrn scholz in kiew sehen haben sie
noch mal eine einladung ausgesprochen
so dass ich dachte sie fragen mich jetzt
nicht reden kannst du das scholz umarmen
ich würde wissen sie ich bin bereit
jeden deutschen politiker jede deutsche
politiker zu umarmen der ukraine hilft
uns zu helfen bereich bereit ist wir
haben gestern kontakte zu
dem kannst du schon gehalt und wir haben
eine einladung ausgesprochen er ist sie
jederzeit willkommen zum datum des ihm
passt und wir schätzen unsere beziehung
das heißt die deutsch ukrainisch und
darüber hinaus glaube ich auch dass die
ukraine und deutschland die länder sind
deren politik und deren entscheidungen
auch die zukunft europas definieren wir
tun das im augenblick auf dem
schlachtfeld weil wir europa
gegen die aggressiven aktionen russlands
verteidigen und deutschland trägt eine
große verantwortung auch für die
europäische union und ihrer zukünftigen
entwicklung das heißt wir möchten
natürlich eine starke und freundliche
beziehung zwischen deutschland und der
ukraine haben die auf der grundlage
gegenseitigen respekts und offenheit und
ehrlichkeit basiert
ich danke für das gespräch und alles gut
denkt vielen dank
der krieg hat nicht nur zu einem
umdenken in deutschland geführt eine
fundamentale zeitenwende gibt es auch im
norden europas dass sich schweden und
finden und höchstwahrscheinlich in die
nato begeben hätte man noch vor drei
monaten nicht für möglich gehalten in
finnland haben sich die staatsspitzen
heute dazu eindeutig positioniert für
die nato wäre finnland ein unverhoffter
gewinn eine verlässliche demokratie mit
enormer militärischer wucht ein land zu
dessen geschichte gehört das ist eine
unabhängigkeit gegen die sowjetarmee
verteidigte die sogenannten winterkrieg
40 zeigten die finden dass ein kleines
land der roten armee schwere verluste
zufügen konnte auch aus diesen
erfahrungen heraus ist finnland bis
heute ein bis unter die zähne
bewaffneter staat als fed bereit zu
landes die kurse berichtet
gerade fand wieder eine internationale
militärübung in finnland statt obwohl
das land noch nicht nato mitglied ist
sieht man seit jahren gemeinsam ins
manöver nur 55 millionen einwohner hat
finnland aber fast 900.000 soldaten und
reservisten ein grund dafür die lange
grenze zu russland
wir haben immer konsequent gehandelt wir
haben unsere all die jahrzehnte ein
gewisses niveau aufrechterhalten während
die übrigen europäischen länder überlegt
haben sich auf krisenbewältigung zu
konzentrieren bei uns dagegen stand
immer die nationale verteidigung im
mittelfeld eine nato-mitgliedschaft
finnlands wird tag für tag
wahrscheinlicher präsident minister und
ministerpräsidenten marien erklärten
heute schriftlich
als ein nato-mitglied würde finnland die
verteidigungsgemeinschaft stärken
finnland muss die nato-mitgliedschaft
unverzüglich beantragen wir hoffen dass
die nationalen schritte für die
entscheidung schnell innerhalb der
nächsten tage erfolgen
der finnische außenminister pkh visto
erläuterte dem europäischen parlament
per videoschalte die sicherheitsdebatte
der vergangenen monate in seinem land
bisher war eine mehrheit der film gegen
die nato mitgliedschaft aber in diesem
frühling hat sich alles verändert die
menschen fühlen sich bedroht auch der
einsatz von nicht konventionellen waffen
hat zu dem meinungsumschwung geführt
deshalb brauchen wir eine bessere
zusammenarbeit
russlands präsident putin ließ kramer
sprecher christoph auf die finnischen
absichten reagieren
die nato rückt weiter an uns natürlich
müssen wir diese lage analysieren und
geeignete maßnahmen für unsere
sicherheit ergreifen noch im vergangenen
jahr nur ein drittel der finnen für den
nato-beitritt nach neuesten umfragen
sind es nun drei viertel
ich denke es ist nun richtig das zu tun
angesichts der lage in europa und in der
ukraine
wir sind gut damit gefahren nicht am
nato mitglied zu sein nein ich finde wir
sollten das nicht tun am montag wird die
empfehlung von präsident und
ministerpräsidentin im parlament
diskutiert auch dort zeichnet sich eine
mehrheit für den nato-beitritt ab die
soldaten im manöver wollen ihre
persönliche ansicht nicht verraten aber
sie sind überzeugt von der stärke der
finnischen ami
wir haben über die gefahr geredet wenn
nun ein krieg ausbrechen würde wären wir
bereit auswahl mich zu verteidigen
zivilisten brauchen sich darüber keine
gedanken
wie und wann regierung und parlament
gemeinsam in sachen nato beitritt
entscheiden werden fest beschlossen ist
bereits dass militär aufzurüsten mit
mehr als zwei milliarden euro in den
kommenden vier jahren
mit dem krieg und seinen folgen geht es
jetzt auch in den nachrichten erst noch
mal weiter als die g 7 gruppe der
führenden demokratischen
industrienationen wir sicherstellen dass
die ukraine ein bedeutender
getreideexporteure bleibt trotz der
russischen blockade außenministerin
berbalk sagte zu beginn von g7
beratungen in weissenhäuser strand an
der ostsee derzeit seinen 25 millionen
tonnen getreide in ukrainischen helfen
blockiert insbesondere in odessa das
getreide werde dringend in afrikanischen
ländern und im nahen osten gebraucht
der bundestag hat steuerentlastungen
beschlossen als ausgleich für die hohen
energie- und lebensmittelpreise unter
anderem wird der grundfreibetrag
rückwirkend zum ersten januar um 363
euro angehoben die pendlerpauschale wird
ab dem 21 kilometer bereits für dieses
jahr um drei cent erhöht außerdem wird
eine energie pauschale von 300 euro an
steuerpflichtige gezahlt und es gibt
einen kinderbonus von 100 euro
bund länder und kommunen können laut der
neuen steuerschätzung in diesem jahr mit
insgesamt
40,4 milliarden euro mehr einnahmen
rechnen als noch im november
vorhergesagt das geht aus der neuen
steuerschätzung hervor die
finanzminister lenton auch heute in
berlin vorstellte trotz der
mehreinnahmen gebe es allerdings keinen
verteilungsspielraum er verwies zudem
auf die finanziellen auswirkungen von
schon beschlossene entlastungspaket
sowie auf risiken infolge des ukraine
krieges
die polizei in essen hat einen 16
jährigen schüler festgenommen der im
verdacht steht einen anschlag auf eine
schule geplant zu haben in der
elterlichen wohnung fanden die ermittler
waffen und material für den bau einer
bombe sowie rechtsextreme und
ausländerfeindliche schriftstücke auch
die ehemalige und die aktuelle schule
des jugendlichen wurden durchsucht
der trierer bischof stephan ackermann
gibt sein amt als
missbrauchsbeauftragter der deutschen
bischofskonferenz nach gut zwölf jahren
ab er werde die aufgabe zur
herbstvollversammlung der bischöfe im
september zur verfügung stellen
ackermann teilte mit es brauche
möglichst bald eine neue und breiter
aufgestellte verantwortung struktur
damit die katholische kirche in
deutschland der vielschichtigkeit der
thematik und der dimension des
aufgabenfeldes künftig noch mehr gerecht
werden könne
zum ersten mal seit beginn der korona
pandemie hat nordkorea offiziell
infektionen bestätigt bei tests in der
hauptstadt pjöngjang sei eine omikron
südvariante nachgewiesen worden
berichten staatsmedien machthaber kim
jong il nun landesweit einen harten
lockdown verhängen das abgeschottete
nordkorea hatte bislang keinen einzigen
corona fall gemeldet daran gab es jedoch
schon länger zweifel
diese woche steht ja wieder eine
landtagswahl an im großen nordrhein
westfalen wie es ausgeht ist noch
relativ offen die forschungsgruppe
wahlen hat für uns ein politbarometer
extra für nrw erstellt ganz aktuell das
ist noch keine stunde alt wenn schon
heute landtagswahl wäre käme die cdu
demnach mit ihrem ministerpräsidenten
wüst auf 32 prozent die spd folgt
relativ dicht mit 29 prozent die fdp
käme auf 6 die afg auf 7 prozent die
grünen würden eine starke dritte kraft
im land mit 17 prozent die linke schafft
es mit nur drei prozent nicht in den
landtag
das rennen zwischen cdu und spd noch
nicht gelaufen ist zeigt auch die frage
nach der ministerpräsidenten präferenz
40 prozent hätten lieber hendrik wüst
35 prozent sprechen sich für seinen
herausforderer thomas kutschaty aus bei
einem starken amtsbonus für wüst müsste
der abstand größer sein und wie immer
gilt solche umfragen sind nur
momentaufnahmen
zumal einige wähler auch noch
unentschlossen sind 66 prozent sagen
dass sie sich ihre wahlentscheidung
sicher sind 34 prozent immerhin rund ein
drittel überlegen noch
heute abend standen sich die beiden
kandidaten ums spitzenamt beim tv duell
gegenüber dort ferber hat das für uns
beobachtet
hendrik wüst und thomas kutschaty im
dritten vergleich das gab es in diesem
wahlkampf kaum heute abend stehen sich
nun beide gegenüber und streiten im
tv-duell stichwort innere sicherheit
der polizist den polizisten besserer
ausstattung auch eine zeitgemäße
digitale aus strategischer neues
polizeigesetz gemacht das war so gut
dass sogar die spd von dem coach die
wende zugestimmt haben es erst so gut
gemacht und
besser die polizei kommt nicht erst wenn
die tat passiert ist und ist schnell da
gewesen sondern wir schaffen es endlich
mal im vorfeld auch etwas dagegen zu tun
hendrik wüst hat vor sechs monaten das
amt des nrw ministerpräsidenten vom
glücklosen armin laschet übernommen
gerade lang genug um bekannt zu werden
aber zu kurz um einen amtsbonus
aufzubauen wüst muss also um stimmen
kämpfen und beherrscht den umgang mit
den bildern mit
kinderwagen der kleinen tochter kommt er
zum amtsantritt in den landtag als
moderner familienvater will wüst sich
neu erfinden bekannt wurde er als
vorstand ihrer cdu generalsekretär im
land abteilung attacke
2017 wird er dann verkehrsminister im
kabinett laschet jetzt heißt es schnell
populär werden der konservative beweist
wandlungsfähigkeit befürwortet den
mindestlohn spricht über soziales und
wohl tatsächlich auf
als ich das amt des ministerpräsidenten
übernommen habe hat meine partei 13
prozentpunkte hinter der spd gelegen
heute legen wir in den aktuellsten
umfragen mindestens 2 prozent vorne also
die richtung stimmt jetzt noch der
rückenwind aus schleswig holstein
ich bin guter dinge
spd herausforderer thomas kutschaty hat
in den vergangenen wochen 300
wahlkampfauftritte absolviert er war
wenig bekannt im land kutschaty hat eine
sozialdemokratische bilderbuch biografie
geborenen essen aus kleinen
verhältnissen er studiert als erster in
der familie jura wird später
justizminister im kabinett hannelore
kraft im wahlkampf setzt kutschaty auf
prominente unterstützung wirbt mit
bundeskanzler scholz gemeinsam für nrw
und deutschland
das merke bei den menschen hier kommt
das an wie er seinen kurs fährt in der
politik gegen russland und wir wollen
auch deutlich machen es ist wichtig dass
in nordrhein westfalen eine regierung
da ist die auch eng mit der
bundesregierung zusammen arbeitet die
wählerinnen und wähler hat in diesen
tagen blumen gleichermaßen vom kutschaty
und von wüst am sonntag müssen sie dann
entscheiden
und jetzt eins mit nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft da gibt es derzeit ja
unsicherheit mit blick auf die
gasversorgung russland hat sanktionen
gegen eine reihe von unternehmen
erlassen und das hat auch folgen für die
gasversorgung deutschlands
wirtschaftsminister habeck hält die
auswirkungen der sanktionen für
überschaubar von bethmann was heißt das
wie sieht es im moment mit der
gasversorgung aus wo man hinhört stehen
am abend die zeichen wieder auf
entwarnung die versorgung sei stabil die
versorgungssicherheit weiter
gewährleistet sagt die bundesnetzagentur
am morgen sah die lage zunächst anders
aus 31 unternehmen bekommen kein gas
mehr aus russland darunter gazprom
germania die firma steht seit april
unter der kontrolle der
bundesnetzagentur
es zeigt also dass die
auseinandersetzung um energie an der
waffe ist und dass energie in einem
wirtschafts konflikt hat eingesetzt
werden kann am mittag der nächste
auftritt die botschaft gas aus russland
fließt weiter die neuen maßnahmen aus
moskau überschaubar wir haben
eine lieferung die nicht mehr erfolgt in
einer menge von 10 millionen kubikmeter
gas täglich aus russland auch das ist
eine menge die kompensierbar ist und die
unternehmen sind dabei das gas über
andere quellen zu beschaffen rund 25
firmen betreiben in deutschland die
speicher die derzeit wieder zu knapp 40
prozent gefüllt sind das sei kein
spitzenwert für diese jahreszeit aber
ordentlich urteilen fachleute auch an
den finanzmärkten entwich der
anfängliche druck nach deutlich
schwächerem beginn reduzierte der dax am
abend seine verluste am ende nur noch
ein minus von 89 punkten doch die hohen
kursschwankungen im tagesverlauf zeigen
vor allem eines die anleger bleiben
nervös und die preise für gas die
stiegen heute weiter kein wunder
angesichts dieser entwicklung frank
bethmann vielen dank
es gibt unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor schweren gewittern
mit heftigem starkregen und hagel
aktuell für teile bayerns
tennis olympiasieger alexanders wäre
steht beim atp turnier in rom im
viertelfinale zverev setzte sich heute
gegen alex demi moore aus australien
durch mit 6 3 und 7 6 in der runde der
letzten acht trifft am freitag auf den
schienen christian berlin das turnier in
rom gilt als generalprobe für die french
open
sollte es doch so etwas wie ein himmel
geben dann setzte dort albert einstein
auf seiner wolke würde hochzufrieden auf
uns hetzt hinunter sehen und sich zur
feier des tages vielleicht sogar ein
kleines gläschen cognac können das tat
er eher selten denn die wissenschaftler
von heute bestätigen erneut wie recht er
hatte mit seiner relativitätstheorie und
dem was er vor über 100 jahren über
schwarze löcher sagte einstand hätte
wohl auch seine freude an diesem bild
das eine wissenschaftliche sensation ist
astronomen ist es gelungen in unserer
milchstraße ein schwarzes loch zu
fotografieren wie sie es schafften das
absolute nichts sichtbar zu machen
erklärte christina kajaks
die reise der forscher führte in das
herz unserer milchstraße 27 tausend
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt
entdeckten sie was sie seit jahrzehnten
vermutet hatten ein schwarzes loch ein
riese mit vier millionen mal der masse
unserer sonne
auf dem foto das sie heute der welt
präsentierten erkennt man wie gase um
das loch herumwirbeln und licht das von
der gewaltigen schwerkraft abgelenkt in
eine gekrümmte waren gezwungen wird man
sieht die gravitation amberg
[Musik]
das ist eine enorme faszination die ist
das alles was um das schwarze loch sich
bewegt licht gas materie aufgesogen wird
dass auch wir wenn wir hinfliegen würden
darin verschwinden würden und es kommt
keine information zurück das sind alles
aspekte die so krass unvorstellbar sind
dass sie eben eine faszination
ausüben auf jeden der letztlich
verstehen will wie ist unsere welt
gemacht wie hängt sie zusammen
das unvorstellbare sichtbar machen dafür
ist das event horizon teleskop im
einsatz ein verbund von radioteleskopen
weltweit in großer höhe aufgestellt
blicken sie in das zentrum von galaxien
acht super teleskope zur gleichen zeit
auf dieselbe stelle ausgerichtet
vernetzt zu einer einzigen kamera von
der größe der erde so gelangen der
spektakuläre beweis für das schwarze
loch das der deutsche nobelpreisträger
reinhard genzel schon vor jahren
berechnet hatte eine bestätigung für
einsteins relativitätstheorie und ein
wichtiger schritt um das mysterium der
schwarzen löcher zu begreifen
in etwa im gleichschritt mit dem der
galaxien dieser so ein fast
symbiotisches zusammen leben und sach
und zwar seit der frühesten zeit kurz
nach dem urknall ist die erste milch
straßen entstanden sind und das ist also
eine ganz unerwartete geschichte die wir
jetzt lernen und wir wollen natürlich
auch ende wissen wer die hände und das
einig weil wir wären zuerst wenn wenn
ich beide gleichzeitig
[Musik]
2009 10 sorgte das erste foto des
schwarzen lochs m87 weltweit für
aufsehen heute nun das neue bild aus
unserer milchstraße
zwei schnappschüsse die aber noch kein
vollständiges bild ergeben mit filmen so
hoffen sie ließen sich auch
veränderungen der geheimnisvollen
giganten beobachten und ihre rolle im
universum besser verstehen
so viele von uns maybrit illner hat
gleich im anschluss eine gesprächsrunde
zu den wirtschaftlichen folgen von krieg
und pandemie zu gast ist unter anderem
finanzminister christian lindner und um
0.30 meldet sich der gorilla pause mit
unserem heutigen update bis morgen hab
wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die konzentration der
treibhausgase speziell in der atmosphäre
nehmen immer weiter zu und vor allem
kohlendioxid und der wert von 420 ppm
wurde im vergangenen monat im schnitt
überschritten das hat es vorher bisher
noch nicht gegeben aber man sieht hier
auch dass die konzentration über die
jahre immer weiter zunimmt trend
eindeutig ansteigen und das schon seit
jahrzehnten wie man hier sieht die kurve
startet ende der 50er jahre und bis in
die gegenwart steigt die konzentration
immer weiter an ja und die menge die sie
hier sehen die wir der atmosphäre
hinzugefügt haben die entspricht etwa
dem übergang von der eiszeit in die warm
zeit aber nicht in tausenden von jahren
sondern in wenigen jahrzehnten
wir schauen aufs wetter und da haben wir
es mit heftigen schauern und gewittern
zu tun die hängen mit dieser kaltfront
zusammen die schleift hier an den alpen
entlang und so gibt es im süden vor
allem diese heftigen gewitter in den
nächsten stunden dabei ist dann
starkregen hagel und sturm dabei im
norden regnet es auch und dazu
temperaturen im einstelligen bereich im
norden und süden ist es deutlich milder
mit 12 bis 16 grad morgen tagesverlauf
weitere schauer und gewitter im süden
die kaltfront ist hier noch aktiv ganz
im norden ziehen auch einige schauer
durch dazwischen gibt es viel
sonnenschein bei höchsten temperaturen
von 15 grad an der nordsee und 25 im
südwesten ja das wochenende wird sonnig
und warm und montag gibt es neue
gewitter durchaus im unwetter bereich
ein schöner abend